嘿，你最近有沒有聽說一個很特別的 AI 應用？有人開始用 AI 工具「無聲無息」地記錄下所有的對話，而且對方完全不知道。
無聲無息地記錄？這聽起來有點…出乎意料，怎麼說呢？一般公司或個人，要嘛會明講，要嘛就是會避開。誰會去悄悄地做這種事？這不就是違反了基本的信任嗎？
我一開始也覺得有點怪，但仔細想，這背後其實是追求效率。根據《華爾街日報》的報導，現在有些 AI 應用程式像 Granola，它不需要像機器人一樣跳進會議室，也不會發出任何通知，就能直接透過你的裝置麥克風錄音。
喔？所以，它不是一個獨立的參與者？這點倒是特別。這樣就真的不會被發現。不過，這種做法真的能撐得久嗎？成本划算嗎？而且，大家都能接受嗎？
成本部分，目前的報導沒有提到具體數字，但從它今年已經募到 1.25 億美元，估值達到 15 億美元來看，我想市場是看好它未來有獲利潛力的。至於接受度，這就是爭議點了。
爭議點確實是關鍵。這不只是在工作場合，報導還提到有人用它來記錄第一次約會、治療、看醫生，甚至是朋友聚餐，而且都沒有告知對方。這感覺已經超出工作效率的範疇了。
對，這就是讓人詫異的地方。我們習慣了任何錄音都要先告知，或至少有明顯的提示。但這些工具讓「環境式錄音」變得太過 frictionless，也就是太順暢、太無感了。
frictionless…這確實是個關鍵字。如果我是個創業主，我會從這裡學到什麼？這種隱形記錄的方式，在提升效率的同時，肯定也帶來了倫理和法律的灰色地帶。
我想，如果從正面思考，它啟發我們去思考如何利用 AI 在「不打擾」的前提下，提升工作效率和知識管理。例如，Michelle Lim，會議軟體公司 Flint 的執行長，她就說她希望 Granola 能在她進入的每個房間都運行。這說明了專業人士對於自動化記錄的需求是很強烈的。
所以，她們看中的是它能把所有的對話都變成文字，方便事後查詢、整理？但這種「無告知」的做法，在台灣或很多國家恐怕會有法律問題。
你說的沒錯，原文有提到，在美國有 11 個州，包括加州、佛羅里達、伊利諾州和賓州，都需要所有參與者的同意才能錄音，否則可能觸犯竊聽法。所以，這是我們應用時必須非常謹慎考量的。
那一般上班族呢？這個概念能帶入自己的工作或生活嗎？比如說，我今天開會，但老闆沒用這種工具，我可以自己悄悄錄嗎？
如果是自己工作上的記錄，例如為了方便回顧會議重點，或許可以考慮。但同樣的，如果涉及到同事或客戶的對話，還是要考量倫理與法律規範。畢竟，不是所有國家或公司都接受。
這點我是信了，因為報導中也提到，人資認證機構的執行長 Amy Dufrane 就說，AI 筆記工具帶來巨大的組織風險，甚至建議公司不應該使用。這表示企業在導入前會非常謹慎。
不過，這也提醒了我們，當 AI 工具越來越便宜、越來越隱形時，這個問題就不只是會不會擴散，而是還有沒有人會先問過同意。這個趨勢好像也提醒了我們，在科技便利與人際信任之間，我們需要找到一個平衡點。